let's see who else I can pick up on here
how about let's go to the nine one seven
area code if indeed that is someone in
New York City would love to hear what is
going on there it's me yes it is hi how
are you good how are you who's this this
is Avery great what's going on um oh
good I have a couple of questions okay
um I'm a software engineer and I'm very
unsure how this entire election will
proceed it it seems it seems that the
American people aren't very trustworthy
when it comes to elect you know online
elections and I'm unsure how voting
turnout will be hold on mom who's early
who's voting online
I mean online voting yeah where what
states are doing online voting Trenton
I don't know I don't know if states are
going to be doing online voting but this
is my word but I think any word about
the question is in person versus
vote-by-mail mm-hmm mm-hmm
yeah oh okay I see yeah
okay so it's going to be voting by mail
well hopefully yeah I mean that's the
idea
all right the state will transfer to
voting by mail
okay all right and it's not even really
a transfer I mean in in reality so this
is an important distinction what we're
really talking about is just expanding
the absentee ballot systems that are
already there like every state already
has an absentee ballot system some
states like Oregon have been exclusively
vote by mail since the 90s so we're not
really talking about creating any new
systems we're just scaling up the
existing vote by mail systems that are
there ah all right okay was this
something that I've been that have been
quite worried about yeah but I haven't
quite done enough research in so thanks
for that clarification
but I also have another another question
that has been quite bothering me of late
I'm
not particularly left-wing or right-wing
for that matter I'm more I'm more
centrist and I don't see and I don't
understand why people are so anti-trump
I've you know i sat here on on the phone
for 20 minutes listening to whatever his
name was because names manrique and he
was calling Trump a thief and a criminal
evil I see people in your comments um
you know I heard I just read one likes
it was an hour ago that Trump raised the
thirteen-year-old girl these these are a
outrageous claims well hold on let's
let's take a step back let's address a
couple different things so first of all
Trump was accused of raping a 13 year
old girl she ultimately you know dropped
the suit because it appears that there
was huge huge pressure but that that's
that that is the allegation to say that
it's true you know we don't have proof
of that I wouldn't look at YouTube
comments necessarily but listen the
reason Trump is so bad is he is
incompetent in a way that is lethal it
is lethal competence a hundred 100
percent he that's very pathetic Bendi
increase the deficit spending without
cutting without cutting the budget yeah
but that doesn't make him that doesn't
make them evil or that's that's not that
that is not political football they all
do that but the the the lethal
incompetence the corruption the doing
the opposite of everything he promised
the hypocrisy double standards I think
with this is where I'm not I'm not quite
following a guy I understand I
understand all from some economics
perspective I see and I understand what
he's doing wrong okay from a leadership
point of view I see how he's incompetent
okay
it runs his mouth and how it could be
dangerous especially when handling
people like the president of China and
the president of North Korea yeah I see
all of this okay and I'm I'm particular
not so I'm not a big fan of Trump for
that reason but from the left I see a
big you know a big character attack
against Trump sure he has a big mouth
and whatnot but um okay but hold on so
you're saying that Trump is terrible on
economics and his leadership has been a
failure but you're not sure why the left
dislikes him so much I mean like that's
why you know and sir you know to the
extent that you don't like the tone of
the left it's you know if that's really
what we're saying you don't like the way
that some of the left criticizes him
okay I mean I don't know it doesn't seem
like a huge deal it's you know we're
gonna talk about tone we've got to look
at Trump but you said it yourself he's
bad on economics and he's a failed
leader I wouldn't say he's a sales
leader per se he didn't do things that
for Mike for my um his foreign policy is
okay from my perspective
he's not he's most certainly not the
most competent man I would vote for but
I don't I don't quite I don't quite
understand why there's such a harsh
reaction from the left so it sounds
every like I see all north of um you
don't like Trump but you you don't like
Trump and you you're not exactly on the
same page with the left as to the degree
to which you don't like him is that sort
of what you're saying well yes well that
that's one thing but I mean I don't
quite understand why it's so hard
I see the left always looking for angles
to attack Trump on on you know with
always a whole Russia gate conspiracy
here net lasted for years years will be
a winner for years yeah yeah yeah that's
true but this whole scandal just went
for years and then he plopped on its
head and I kept hearing on the news
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia Russia well now it sounds
like there it's about the news not so
much about the left-right
I'm having trouble it's weird I'm having
trouble following what your argument is
I guess you just don't think the left I
don't know certainly have an argument
I'm trying to I'm trying to ask you why
why is there this wise of this
particular harsh view of Trump and this
constant attack and trying to find the
angles on them you know finding angles
it's you don't really need to go finding
angles you're talking about a guy who is
in completely over his head doesn't
listen to experts thinks he knows more
than everybody seems emotionally
unstable doesn't understand economics
doesn't understand public policy doesn't
understand foreign policy doesn't
understand geopolitics can't take
responsibility for a single a single
mistake and is regularly making errors
that lead to people dying as we are
seeing with coronavirus I don't know
what you know if you just don't see that
as warranting people on the left being
upset then we probably just have
different values in the end well I don't
know I don't see I hear I saw your
latest video where Trump accused latest
video of yours on your channel where
Trump accused um I think it was a report
no it wasn't a reporter a TV show host
of accuse him of murder yes and then and
then you didn't say anything anything
particularly you didn't lay you know the
coronavirus dips on his feet but I saw
many you know as how many people who did
yeah from is not responsible from is not
responsible for 100,000 deaths but just
one week earlier of saying we've got to
shut things down could have saved 30,000
people two weeks earlier could have
saved 50 so certainly Trump is not
responsible for coronavirus but his
inaction is certainly tied to some of
the deaths listen my friend I got a run
but I I guess I understand you just
you're not you don't see why the left
dislikes Trump so much and and that's
fine it sounds like we have we have sort
of different ways of evaluating and
that's that's okay but I'm just trying
to tell you why many on the Left do see
this as a lethally incompetent man
that's all the time I have for calls
today sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again